[Music]
on this saturday night the compromise at
cop26
the overtime session at the climate
summit and what it means for coal i
propose that the revised
proposal is adopted the covet crisis in
yukon we're back in a state of emergency
with very significant public health
measures being put in place the
widespread untraceable infections the
solution for burnout in canada's health
care system plus the canadians refusing
to leave the dangerous political
situation in haiti
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with breaking news from
glasgow tonight delegates at cop 26 have
finally reached an agreement but a
last-minute change to the text proposed
by india has infuriated many countries
and prompted the president of the
climate summit to say sorry i apologize
for
the way this process has unfolded
and
i'm deeply sorry
the change weakens the language on the
use of coal in the efforts to cut
emissions redmond shannon has our top
story tonight
cop 26 president talak sharma warned
delegates there would be no double
overtime after talks spilled over from
friday's deadline it is my intention
that we will close
this cop this afternoon with a third
draft on the table delegates gave their
final thoughts
the difference between 1.5 and 2 degrees
is a death sentence for us most
admitting the text was imperfect but no
deal would be far worse but for heaven's
sake
don't kill this moment
by
asking for more text different text
deleting this deleting that members of a
group of developing nations insisted
they need help to deal with climate loss
and damage caused by emissions that
historically have come from the west
we refuse
to get trapped
in the carbon colonialism
others including china south africa and
india raised concerns over the text
calling for an end to inefficient fossil
fuel subsidies
developing countries have a right to
their fair share of the
global carbon budget
and are entitled
to the responsible use of fossil fuels
as delegates convened to vote a
last-minute intervention by india and
china secured a change committing to a
phasing down of coal power without
offsets rather than a phasing out
many were furious feeling blindsided but
now we learn that there are even further
changes that we were not being made
aware
the cop president emotional and
apologetic
i'm deeply sorry
but i think as you have noted
it's also vital that we
protect this package
experts say the previous draft was not
enough to limit global warming to 1.5
degrees this tweak likely makes that
goal even harder to reach i think that
this
is it's a meek weak outcome that doesn't
meet the moment of the climate emergency
but getting 197 countries to sign off
was always going to need painful
compromises redmond shannon global news
london the climate crisis will be on the
agenda next week in washington when
prime minister trudeau meets with u.s
president joe biden and mexican
president andres manuel lopez obrador
the leaders will attend the first three
amigos summit since 2016. mercedes
stephenson has been talking to canada's
ambassador in washington about the
issues mercedes
robin canadians will be keeping a close
eye on the relationship between
president joe biden and prime minister
justin trudeau while the two
administrations have similar ideologies
there have been bumps along the road and
strains in the relationship under the
biden presidency including a buy
american plan that would favor a
protectionist approach to trade that
would hurt canadian companies bottom
lines there's also concern that trade
protectionism is expanding to the auto
industry and could undermine the
long-standing economic cooperation
between the two countries on that file
canada is also fighting to keep the line
5 pipeline in business as the state of
michigan has been trying to shut it down
critics have suggested that canada has
fallen off the radar of the biden
administration and doesn't have the
prominence ottawa once enjoyed as the
united states closest ally this week on
the west block i asked canada's
representative in washington ambassador
kirsten hillman if canada is struggling
to get points across to the
administration in the white house or at
the capitol and trying to get folks to
pick up the phones she says that's not
the case i never have any challenges
getting
in to talk to the biden administration
when i have something that canada needs
to talk to them about whether that's the
white house or you know cabinet
secretaries our ministers are able to
contact them i'm able to contact them
i'll also talk to the ambassador about a
joint approach between canada and the
u.s on the china file what's going on in
washington as the two countries try to
navigate the troubled waters of china's
rising political and military power
paired with an apparent willingness for
diplomatic confrontation china is a an
enormous
consequential country that impacts
almost every aspect of the lives of
canadians as well as americans as well
as our allies around the world and we're
all kind of grappling with
how do we have a sophisticated
approach to dealing with this country
that is a very significant country on
the world stage we'll find out more
about what that approach will look like
this week on the west block robin all
right thanks for that mercedes and you
can watch the extended interview of the
west block tomorrow right here on global
to the kova 19 pandemic cases are once
again rising in some provinces leaving
officials to consider their next steps
to limit the spread but the concern is
highest in yukon which has become
canada's coven 19 hot spot abigail
beeman reports
i have the chills
i've been sweating a little bit in the
cough
it certainly feels more like the common
cold than a lethal respiratory virus but
it's hard to tell with case rates in the
yukon by far the worst in the country
jessica kish got a copin 19 test when
she couldn't shake her symptoms and
spent saturday waiting for results the
territory is in a state of emergency new
mask mandates proof of vaccination rules
and capacity limits took effect saturday
in other jurisdictions you can just have
soup delivered to your door you can have
groceries delivered to your door we
don't have those luxuries here the north
has a number of unique characteristics
including being prioritized for the
country's first shots the head of the
canadian medical association says waning
immunity is a factor in climbing cases
we are seeing that that waning i think
potentially now i think the other issue
is with delta it is just so much more
contagious that even when you have you
know 15 of your population unvaccinated
and then of course all children under 12
unvaccinated it is still a lot of people
who are vulnerable cases are up 11
nationwide from last week though
hospitalizations and deaths remain
stable the risk for surges in disease
activity is likely to increase with more
time spent indoors in manitoba new caps
for religious gatherings in the southern
health region took effect saturday the
province also announced kids 12 to 17
will soon need one dose of the vaccine
or a recent negative test to play indoor
sports pharmacists are required to
administer those tests and many say they
were caught off guard we're in favor of
expanding the scope of rapid and
tests administered and interpreted by
pharmacists and we just encourage
you know
government to
consult us on on these types of things
in the future as well
so that we can avoid avoid confusion for
the public in ontario toronto's mayor
dropped in on a new shop and vax clinic
the city trying to get creative about
getting people the jab the progress is
happening at a slower pace than when we
could count on thousands of people lined
up at vaccine clinics but progress is
still happening like other jurisdictions
toronto is also focused on a plan to
vaccinate children with a decision on
pfizer's pediatric vaccine expected in
the next week or two according to health
canada john tory says the country's
biggest city will be ready as soon as
they get the green light robin abby
goldbeam in ottawa thanks abigail
in the u.s 47 million americans have now
been infected with the virus that's
nearly 15 percent of the population new
cases are increasing by about a million
people every two weeks and at least 14
states are reporting an uptick in
hospitalizations and with american
thanksgiving approaching medical experts
say the situation could get worse
jennifer johnson reports
month after month new cases of cova 19
continue to surge across america jumping
from 33 million to more than 47 million
in the past six months it's really hard
right now hospitals in a handful of
states are overwhelmed again with cobia
19 patients minnesota is now seeing its
fourth deadly wave doctors are pleading
with residents to get vaccinated we are
essentially 100 capacity we've been that
way for weeks increasingly
tough keep going after 20 months of this
hospitals in colorado are swamped too 95
percent of icu beds are filled more than
at any other time during the pandemic
medical workers fear what's coming next
with the holidays and flu season about
to hit i think everybody just worries
where are we at what are we going to do
colorado's governor is so concerned he's
issued an executive order allowing all
adult residents to get coveted 19
boosters following similar orders in
california and new mexico the governor
jumped ahead of federal guidelines which
limit boosters to adults 65 and older or
people with underlying risk factors
please if you got the vaccine six months
or more ago
get your booster
it's a really important part of
protecting yourself it's a really
important part of ending the pandemic in
colorado
the surge in hospitalizations comes as
some workers in large corporations fight
vaccine mandates a federal court in
texas just sided with united airlines
after it placed 2 000 employees on
unpaid leave after they were given
medical or religious vaccine exemptions
but the workers plan to appeal i am all
for medical freedom of choice
and that's what we're fighting for we
will not comply twenty months into this
pandemic americans are still at war tens
of millions of federal workers and large
corporation employees face late november
and early january deadlines to get
vaccinated many remain defiant against
getting the shot while weary doctors and
nurses battle to keep unvaccinated
patients alive
jennifer johnson global news washington
russia's coven 19 situation continues to
get worse the country reached another
daily high for covet 19 related deaths a
record
1241 people died from the virus in the
last day russia has now reported more
than 254 thousand deaths by far the
highest count in europe
less than 40 percent of the country is
fully vaccinated
president vladimir putin is denying
russia has any involvement in the
migrant crisis along the belarus poland
border
he was responding to claims a russian
plane transported migrants from the
middle east to belarus in order to seek
asylum in neighboring european union
countries critics say belarus president
alexander lukashenko engineered the
humanitarian crisis as retaliation for
sanctions on his government thousands of
migrants and refugees have filled
makeshift camps along the border the
situation is growing more concerning
today police in poland say they found
the body of a young syrian man the ninth
person to die so far
coming up the canadians who won't leave
haiti despite living in fear
there is more death in the streets of
sudan a doctors group says security
forces fired live bullets and tear gas
into crowds of protesters killing at
least five people and wounding 40 others
it's the latest crackdown on growing
pro-democracy demonstrations the
military seized power last month
arresting the prime minister and
dissolving the country's transitional
government
a powerful gang leader in haiti says he
will lift a month-long blockade of fuel
terminals that has cut off gas supplies
and made everyday life in the island
nation even more difficult the country
has endured a year of back-to-back
crises the assassination of its
president a powerful earthquake and a
string of kidnappings and as the turmoil
worsens the canadian and u.s governments
have urged all of their citizens to
leave some canadians living in haiti
plan to stay put but say ottawa needs to
do more to help the country kamal
karamali reports
utter and uncontrollable chaos that's
how some haitians describe the state of
their country amid the ongoing gang
violence and kidnappings now a lack of
available fuel is affecting hospitals
and schools this week canada pulled all
non-essential staff from its embassy and
urged citizens to leave immediately
haiti became home
so i definitely don't want to leave
despite the dangers canadian leila
dominique is not leaving she moved there
from montreal seven years ago her family
calls port-au-prince home as difficult
as that is these days you're
relieved that the whole family got home
safe and that's a feeling that you feel
on a daily basis
so you kind of
go like okay we made it we made it
safely we're home
she says she barely escaped a kidnapping
in 2020 at the hands of the powerful 400
mawoso gang her daughters were with her
when friends were abducted from vehicles
traveling nearby they were released a
short while later thanks to a ransom for
me it changed my experience of haiti
because now i live with fear
since then the 400 marozo has only grown
recently making international headlines
for kidnapping 17 missionaries including
one canadian dominique says the canadian
government has been silent throughout
the chaos
they sent an email with a number saying
that they were available for assistance
and
i called and nobody's answering canada's
former ambassador to haiti says that's
because the embassy is likely dealing
with its own disarray no airplane uh no
gas to move vehicles from point a to
point b bad communication so there's
still there is some limit to what we can
do
and as foreigners flee the country this
former elections minister says canadians
and americans leaving will only lead to
more turmoil so we need the support of
the international community
to help us and we cannot do it by
ourselves and now a plea for other
countries to send more resources instead
of stripping them away from a country
that has little left to give kamal
karmali global news
still ahead the red tape facing foreign
trained doctors who want to help
canada's strained health care system
the pandemic has put additional strain
on canada's health care system which was
already facing a backlog of surgeries
then there are nurses burnt out and
leaving the profession at an alarming
rate and millions of canadians are
without a family doctor but a solution
some experts say is waiting in the wings
physicians trained in other countries
but as jamie morocco reports they say
they are still being sidelined by red
tape
motherhood isn't the reason dr saida
azam hasn't been able to work as a
family physician during the pandemic i
really felt bad that i couldn't
participate actively
it's that her years of training and
experience come from india and oman the
30 year old is just one of more than 13
thousand internationally trained
physicians who are not able to work as
doctors in canada
dr shafi buyon who immigrated here in
2010 says the retraining process is
confusing time consuming and costly we
need a policy change to accept and adopt
in this pandemic so that people can help
support
and canada could use the help as covid
stressed the staffing shortage further
some provinces turned to the military to
alleviate overwhelmed icu's bouyon says
it's time to invest in foreign doctors
global competition for health care
talent is now ongoing if canada failed
to take action these people will move
other country but the president of
canada's medical association says it's
not that simple and it's going to be
very difficult to have an approach
that's totally reliant on people coming
from overseas to solve our problems
because again the training and
experience of people can be quite
variable dr hassan mustafa has 10 years
as a surgeon in iraq and syria under his
belt and was a supervising physician at
one of the largest refugee camps in
kurdistan under the current system it
would take him five years to get
certified at 45 he says the clock is
ticking respect my experience
no
i work a lot before i have a lot of
experience experience he is willing to
put towards a less skilled job such as a
surgical assistant just to get into the
system
a zom meantime plans to make a career
change i'm looking forward to you know
apply for other causes like physician
assistant stepping back so she can step
forward into her new life here in canada
jamie morocco global news toronto
up next the indigenous guardians keeping
tabs on moose on cape breton island
they call themselves indigenous
guardians a network of 70 groups across
canada their formal network is only five
years old but the work they do goes back
hundreds of generations monitoring
managing and caring for land water
plants and animals on their territories
each guardian program is run locally as
distinct as the first nations they
represent our donna friesen got access
to one group with the big mon nation
tracking moose in cape breton also known
as unamagi
this as the buffalo is important to the
plains indians so is
the moose to the migma clifford has to
contend with a different kind of
conservation problem how many moose
would be
in the highlands here do you think the
last estimate was 2400 give or take so
from a migma perspective a healthy herd
is dependent on a healthy ecosystem so
2400 we think it's good because the
carrying capacity
of the ecosystem serves the population
better than having a hyper-abundant
population moose weren't always so
abundant a century ago the population
was wiped out another species from
alberta was introduced and with no
natural predators left it flourished so
today in the absence of wolves in
unamagi in nova scotia what's going to
keep the population in check is the
humans the human human interaction
without hunting moose would overrun the
highlands and over feed on the saplings
that regenerate the boreal forest
traditionally the migma would head
inland to hunt this time of year a way
of life disrupted by colonialism i have
the right to do this
but more importantly have the
responsibility and the migma fought so
hard for those rights they fought
incredibly hard for those rights
put
and how many were in your hunting party
that's where the guardians come in
hannah martin is with the confederacy of
mainland migma it's a really important
time for us as mgmaw people to be on the
land here in unamagi and
harvesting this resource it's more than
just a harvest it's everything for us
when a moose is harvested the antlers
are measured samples are collected
details from the hunters are recorded
all vital information to track and
monitor the health of the population
and you can catch donna's full
documentary tonight on the new reality
at 7 pm right here on global
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada is kananaskis country in
alberta we would love to see your corner
of the country so please keep sending
your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]